hey guys welcome to the don't laugh
challenge with Brian Ryan Matt Ryan is
going to take a sip of this water and
then we're gonna do our damndest to try
to make him laugh we got like a minute
to make him laughing if he doesn't laugh
he wins if he does laugh he sprays water
probably all over the camera but the
rules just to just before anyone yeah or
that we can't touch it we can get right
up on we can't like tickle em you know
touch him we can do anything but let
that take your sip he's already laughing
I can O notation of it okay and go do
you remember what sounding is it's where
you put the penis don't look your mind
look who's behind it okay did you
swallow that ooh oh okay good enough all
right how much time we got
oh oh thanks Brian
oh come on all right man
sure what you want to change position
yeah I'll be over here to send three to
one week 21 ah
Homer Simpson d'oh this guy smells
amazing yeah I've noticed that my god
plenty of one
the usual stuff isn't working for
apparently not enough he's like a stone
Rock of impassiveness why do memes were
committed why are you the meme Lord why
it's only more convenient
I got me pretty good there once was a
man from Peru who dreamt he was eating
his shoe he woke in the night with a
terrible fright and found that he had a
man giant hot gaudy
see everyone
I don't even though the camera would be
able to pick this out
I think they couldn't hear any and go
there you have folks showing your ass I
Brian get ready show me your Apple my
ass show your ass now I almost saw
another ass - Brian is the winner is the
winner so far Ron's gonna go again
because I think it's funny all right
- angle I really want to just break the
rules now just punch it with the stomach
you tell me more about these ghetto fine
yeah what's the name of the Deez Nuts
guys welven welven the welven they guys
are parents in Ingham welcome what the W
yeah okay you know the Maghrib ebooks
girl oh yeah
negatives are gold rings - you just dick
these nuts guy LeBron James
whispering just like besides my home all
right so uh Matt's gonna go again
because and go
did you see my tool right that's oddly
the shape of Ryan's penis I just
absolutely time right here yeah because
of the hammer and sagu should be
repeating this is the gloss little
finishing towards blanks full-time yeah
I want to do one more
congratulations you did I did it man it
was close though time they were actually
working against you because I was
laughing at the baby's house laughter
the Vinny's house laughter the Vinny's
house laughter ah he's the undisputed
champion but I think we have a way pull
out all the stops
all the stops whatever you got tell us
about your PhD we'll just what is PhD
stamp work pretty hard dick drawn a
blank
well do something for the baby it may be
like this all day enjoy that yeah that's
the vows curse we didn't make Brian lab
which could be that we're not funny but
also well actually that's a tiny problem
I'm totally dead inside yeah yeah he has
no soul he sold it for his PhD just a
husk yeah so we did the best we could
so let us know how we could have done
better and you obviously could have made
him laugh because your YouTube comments
and that what you could do so don't do
everything they can do that man
I believe so thank you everybody so much
for watching let me know what you think
of this game in the comments down below
and as always we'll see you in the next
video
but I
you